みなさんこことこのビデオ
では、日本での勉強についてお話します。
大学の4年制大学の学位に集中し
ます。
それを本当に理解していない人がたくさんいると思うからです。
アメリカの高校や
世界の他の場所から日本の大学に直接
行くことができるようになったので、これは私がこの特定のトピックについてツイッターで受け取ったたくさんの質問に答えるもう一つの長い形式のビデオになるでしょう
しかし
、始める
前に、それらの質問の前にいくつかの小さなことについて話したかった
ので、最初
に言いたいのは、これは即席
であり、また、
私が以前働いていたちょっとした裏話でもあるということです
日本の主要大学の入学事務局な
ので
、この
トピックに関しては、私は主に国内の
日本人学生または国内の学生を対象としている
ので、 日本
国籍ですが、アジアパシフィック大学でベットブックで働いていた大学に
は、
留学生
と日本人学生の半分がいるので、アメリカに行くのが彼らの仕事だっ
たたくさんの人々と同じオフィスで働きました。
アメリカの高校に、私が勉強したワシントン大学の
ように行くよりも、APUに来てそこで勉強するのは良い考えかもしれ
ないと説得するために、これは逸話であり
、このビデオの情報は少しかもしれませ
ん フェアだったので少し古いです
が、
本当に活発に働いてから約1年が経ちました
ので、少し親休みでし
たので、そう言いますが、
えーと、他に話したいこと
があります 詳細に入る前に、
このビデオを見ているすべての人に最初に表現したい最も重要なことは、
このビデオは
主に学生向けであると思います。
すぐに大学に行くか
、日本の大学院のようなものを考えているかもしれませんが
、ほとんどは
学部生ですが、
すぐに大学に行く人は、最初に
強調したいのはあなたです 自分に問いかける
必要があるのは、
大学が必要なのは、私が本当にやりたいことのために必要な大学の学位を与える
こと
です。つまり、時代は非常に
急速に変化しており、現在YouTubeで行っているようなことをして
いるのです。
-私が2005年に大学に進学し始めたときの仕事で
、今では
別の大きな爆発的な
市場があり
ます。それは
、ストリーミング
ビデオゲームやストリーミングチャットなどでプロのストリーマーになる
ことができるような、ひきつりのようなビデオゲームです。
将来的には、現在は存在しない、さらに多くの機会があり、
これを念頭に置いて
、大学に行く必要があるかどうかを自問する必要があります。
その特定のキャリアのために私がやりたいことをするために、
それを置くための最良の方法
は、あなたが
月に3000ドルか4000ドルを
得ることができるかどうかだと思います。
何かをするために月に4000ドルあなたが何をするかという
答えは
、あなたがあなたの仕事をあなたのキャリアにし、
あなたが答えたばかりの質問があなたが何かをすることが
できるかどうか知っているようにするためにあなたがしようと努力することです それでお金をもらって
、やってみて、もう一度自問してみてください。それをうまくやるに
は大学の学位が
必要です。
それで、日本での勉強に移りましょう。
これは非常に複雑なトピックです。
私がアメリカの大学に行き始めたとき、ある種の裏話を立てるつもりでした。
最終的に日本に引っ越して日本で働きたいと思っている人の一般的な考え
は、アメリカの大学に
行く必要があるということでした。 だってw 日本
の大学に直接行くことは基本的に不可能な
ので、学位を取得し、
できればジェットプログラムで日本に来
て、それを
3〜4年間行った後、
別のキャリアに移行して、おそらく
翻訳や
もう少し専門的なものになります
日本での広告や販売がわからないよう
に
、東京でも少しやりましたが、このダイナミクス
は完全に変化しており
、米国の高校から直接、またはどこからでも行くことができるようになりました。
日本の大学
に行くことです。また、米国
から直接行き、就職せずに
就労ビザを取得して
、観光ビザで日本に来て
、そのビザで就職して就職することも可能です。
そうしている間、雇用主
はあなたのためにビザを変更するので、
それはもう少し難しいですが、
それは可能です、そしてそれ
は私が日本でのデートについてビデオを作った私のいとこです
h  eは観光ビザで日本
に来ました。来る前に、彼
はさまざまな英国の
学校とオンラインでいくつかのインタビューを並べました。彼は
ジェットプログラムをしていませんでした。彼は
そのビザに直接来て
、 就職の申し出があり、彼らは
今からあなたに就労ビザを提供するつもりだと言いました、そして
それが彼が日本に来た方法
です。
また、
彼がたまたま英語をやっていたとは限りません
が、新しい
機会がたくさん生まれてくる
ので、今からそれについて話
します。私が以前働いていた大学は
、アジアでのメイクと呼ばれています。 パシフィック
大学の学生の半数は
世界中
からの留学生であり、半数は直接
日本国籍を持っているので
、そのグループのほとんどは
明らかに日本国内から来ていますが、私のように
住んでいた日本人学生も含まれています
nアメリカでは、彼らは
日本国籍を持っていましたが、彼らは
アメリカに住んでいたか、
日本国籍を持っていました
が、タイのように、またはどこにでも住ん
でいましたが、
私は博士号が
申し訳ありませんが、私が
話しているすべての学部
生と大学院生
については、かなりの程度ですが
、米国の高校から、または
日本の大学に行く可能性がある場所ならどこでも、宇宙から直接行くことができます ですから、
質問に答える前に、メモを
参照せずにどれだけ言うことができるかを見てみましょう。
今、日本には5つか6つの主要な
大学があります。
私の知る限り受け入れています私は
APUについて確かに知っているだけですが、これは日本で
4年制大学の
通常の学位を取得する学生を受け入れている
のでかなり正確であるはずです。
私が以前働いていたアジアパシフィック大学は
、東京にあるジョルティ大学としても知られるソフィア大学です。
東京にもケイオ大学があり
ます。私はそこに1年間ブロドを始めました。
ワシラ大学
があります。 東京
の郊外に国際クリスチャン大学のようなICUがあります
が、
その学校についての私の理解では
、英語で勉強したいだけの日本人学生にとっては留学生向けではなく、インターネット向けであるため
、ほとんどが日本人学生です。
カリキュラムはすべて英語で
、北大学
沖田国際大学もあります。
北日本にあるIUと呼ばれていると思います。
次に
東京にあるテンプル大学もあるので
、エアコンを下げます。
ここでは少し暑いので、お詫び申し上げます。
これらの大学のすべてではないにしても、ほとんどの大学に
申し込むことができます。
あなたがまだアメリカの高校に
いる間、
大学が日本で伝統的に働いていた方法
は、日本人学生が
可能な限り最高の評判の大学に入るのに本当に一生懸命働くということです。
後で彼らを雇う会社は
基本的に大学の名前だけを見ていたので彼らが入ったので、
彼らは大学にいる間はあまり一生懸命勉強しませんでした
ほとんどの学生は大学にいる間それを
4年のように取るでしょう いわば人生を離れて、
小学校から高校の終わりまで本当に一生懸命勉強
して、
4年間プレーできる最高の大学に
入学し、卒業
したら最高の会社に入学し、 それから
その会社に一生滞在し、それは
非常に奇妙で効果がないように聞こえるかもしれません
が、実際には非常に
長い間システムとして非常にうまく機能し、
それ
は、宇宙を見ただけで、
自分が
有能な学生であるかどうか、
いわば有能な志願者であるかどうか、いわば志願者の大学の名前を知っていることがわかったからです。
人類学や心理学のように完全にランダムなことを勉強したとしても
、たとえばトヨタに行って
、トヨタの工場のように働いていたとしても、
トヨタは自分が賢いことを知っていたので、何を勉強して
もかまいません。
トヨタが1、2年かけて
彼らを訓練した場合、その志願者は
一生一緒にいる可能性が高く、その会社に2年に1回滞在し
た賢い志願者がいる場合
、それ
はそれほど大きな問題ではありません。
日本で物事が機能し
ていた方法は、広い一般化ですが
、一般的には、この
システム大学が日本で機能した方法です
が、過去にはよくやっています
日本が
ますます国際的に
なり、ますますグローバル化するにつれて、50年は本当にそれ以上になるでしょう。文化は
少しずつ変化してきており、
今日では学生にとって、または誰かにとってより一般的です。
転職の仕事があるので、この時点で
大学は
、学生が大学でやったことのようなものを、
彼らが留学した
場合に指導的地位に就いた場合
や、
これもまた、
日本の文化が変化している
ためです。日本は国際化が進んでいる
ため、
英語を話すことができ、米国やヨーロッパなどの
代表的な営業担当者と電話をかけることができる応募者が必要です。
ベトナムでは
あそこの植物のようなものを担当し
ていて、日本の人口が
減っているからです したがって、これらの大学は
留学生の受け入れにも非常に熱心であるため
、私が試してみることができる最善の方法は
、日本の本当の迅速な雇用主が以前
よりも多くなっているということを言いませんでした。 彼ら
は
、JIT
が大学の名前だけでなく、実際
には独自のスキルセットを持っており、主要な
ことの1つである英語で相互作用し、働くことができるという意味で、申請者が資格を持っていることを確認し
たいと考えています。 いわばキャリアパスレベル
私は今、いわば宅配便事務所のように話しているのです
が、学生の観点からすると
、日本のほとんどの高校生が
大学を見ているとき、彼らが探している主なものの1つは
留学できるかどうか
、その国際的な経験を積むことができる
かどうかだけで
なく、留学していなくても留学生と交流できる
かどうか、できるかどうか 日本国内でもグローバルな経験を積む
ことができ、
日本の学生は皆
、大学
が入学プログラムにそれを反映し始め
ていることを望んでいるため、より多くの宇宙
留学生を受け入れ
、英語でより多くのプログラムを提供しています。
私がAPUで働いていた大学
は、日本語や英語
ではないいくつかの言語クラス（
中国語や
タイ語など）や他のいくつかの言語のようないくつかの例外を除いて、
すべての学部クラスで働いていました。 これらの
クラスは
英語または日本語で受講できます。現在
、多くの日本の大学
が英語でコース全体を提供していることも珍しくありません。
そのため、多くの
高校生がここ
で日本の大学に行くことができるという主な関心事があります。
私は日本語は話せませんが、
これは
私が強調したい主なことの1つで
あり、できる必要はありません。 日本の
いくつかの大学に行くために日本語を話し
ます。ここですべての要点を説明したいと思います。
日本の特定の大学に行くために日本語を話す必要はありません。
日本の大学は
通常、米国の大学よりもはるかに安価であり
、日本で働く場合
は、米国の大学
に行ってから、どのような種類の大学に進学するよりも、
とにかく日本の大学を通過する方がよいでしょう。 とても西洋的な職場
環境で
、いわば西洋の仕事のスキルがありますが
、日本で働くつもりなら、いわば日本の視点から
それらの仕事のスキルを身につけたほうがいい
と思います。
いくつかのこと
について私が話したかった主なポイントのいくつかは、
コストの面でapu
は私立大学であり、
1年間の授業は私が
agaについてそこで働いていたときについてです 約1年
前に私はそこで約5年間働いていましたが
、それ
は日本の私立大学であり、実際
にはより高価であり、apu
は特に外部から来る留学生に多くの奨学金を提供しています
日本の大学なので、
2004年のよう
に大学に出願するときにフラッシュした場合、唯一の
選択肢はワシントン大学に行くこと
でしたが、州やその他の場所の高校生の場合は
今のところ、1万ドル以上の授業料がかかる日本の
大学に申し込むことができる可能性は非常に高いですが
、
1万ドルも少し
高いですが、ほとんど
の私立大学にとっては平均的だと思います
KOやwasitのように、
私は少し弱い
と思いますが、同じ球場にありますが、その大学が行うかもしれない特定の奨学金
を取得することは私の理解にとってそれほど難しいことでは
ありません
留学生のために特別に大学に提供するので
、次は話しません。
その大学がより多くの留学生をその大学に
来させるために特別に作成した奨学金について話
しているので
、より多くの留学生を引き付けることが新しい大学の関心事です。 日本人学生
と交流する
ような学生であり、
将来の雇用主
は、日本語だけでなく、日本語と英語、またはその逆を話すことができる学生を雇うことに関心
があります。日本の
多くの雇用主は、
日本人学生を雇うだけでなく、私を雇うことを望んでいます。
英語は話せますが、
私のようなアメリカ人の学生のように、
日本語が話せ
ます。それは
、私が以前と同じような仕事をして
もらいたいと思っているからです。
かつてないほど日本語が話せる欧米人、それは
ますます多くの日本が
グローバル化
が進んでいるので、高校から直接日本大学に出願して進学できるので、アメリカよりもずっと安い
ので、主に費用がかからないので、まずはかなりいいところだ
と思います。 東京の中心部
にいない限り、それは生活費にもなりますが、
それでも
一般的に
は
、安くはないに
しても、APUや秋田のような場所に行く場合は、米国のほとんどの主要大学のほとんどの場所と非常に似ていると思います あるいは
、いわば都市の真ん中にない大学のようなものを
見ると、さらに節約できるので、おそらく
乗り越えられると言っても過言ではないと思います。
授業料と生活費を含めて約1万5千ドルから2万ドルすべての
コース費はすべて私が意味するすべての本
とそのようなもの日本の大学で
は年間1万5千ドルから2万ドルな
ので
、もっと安いと思います アメリカの多くの大学よりも
、時間をかけて適切な
研究をして調べれば、留学生のための奨学金がたくさんあります。それが
私がすべての人に勧めたいこと
ですが、今から試してみます。 ですから、
実際に日本の大学に出願したいと思うかもしれないすべての学生にとっての主なハードルは
、やはり
日本語は問題ではないので
、英語で直接勉強し始めて
、主な
問題が多くの場合に沿って日本語を学ぶことができるからです。 授業料の全部または一部を支払うので
あれば、日本で勉強させてくれるように両親を説得
できるかどうか
。 とにかく授業料
は、州や家族、または
そこにあるようなものと、または
どこからでも、主要な種類の関係がない場合でも、可能であれば自分でその決定を下す方が良いかもしれません omそして
日本に直接来るので、私は文字通り
、高校
を卒業して日本の大学に通い、
現在日本で英語
教育ではなく働いている世界中の何百、何百、何百もの学生を知っています。
マツダ、
ソニー、ニンテンドーのような日本の大手
企業、あるいはデロイトやグーグルビデオのような日本の外国企業でさえ
、すでに
いくつかのビデオゲーム会社について言及しましたが、そうですね、
ソニーニンテンドーは
本当にすべての主要な日本企業
です スバルホンダなどのスーツが思い浮かぶ
ので
、たくさんの人
が主だったとは
思いませんが、そういうことは可能です。
日本では
、州の大学にジェットプログラムに再び参加して
英語を教えてから、
英語英語に関連する何かをするようにしてい
ます。最近は他の選択肢があります。
過去10年ほどで、
これらの新しい大学が登場
し、古い大学が
、日本の大学に直接来
て英語で勉強できる新しいプログラムを提供しているのです。
エンジニアリングや
ロボティクスなどの専門分野で
は、途中で英語を学び、
英語を含むものに入ると、
現在はオプションとなっている日本の大手企業に行って働くことができる
ので、それが私がやりたい主なこと
です。
それが可能だとは知らない
人がたくさんいると思うのです
が、
今は可能になっているので
、日本に来て働きたいと思ったら そして、YouTubeのよう
なものではなく、大学の学位を必要とする特定
のことをしたいのですが、それ
について考えてみてください。 このビデオ
を作ろうとツイートしたときにTwitterで得た具体的な質問
は、
インターンシップで外国人学生を受け入れ
てくれることを願っています。
慶
應大学でヘッドハンティングをし
たので、それは間違いなく可能ですし
、ちなみに
、日本にいる留学生の多くは
、学業や留学をし
ていると思います。ビザビザビザ
20時間程度に制限されていると思います。 日本で学位を取得している間、学生として経済的に自分をサポート
するための良い方法として、
あなたは何をお勧めしますか？
私は
TESOLの認定を取得するために取り組んできましたが、
これは実行可能ですか？
自習に加えて、夕方や週末のセッションに
は多くのパートタイムの仕事の選択肢があります。
ほとんどのパート学生は、
アポに行く留学生
がパートタイムを取得するだけです。
これは
、1年生と2年生のよう
に、3年生と4年生の中には、先ほど話した
ようなインターンシップのようなものです
が、1
年生と2年生の多くは
お金を稼ぎたいの
は、週に20時間、
モスバーガー
やコマビーニーのように
仕事をするか、レストランのウェイトレスやウェイターのようになるか、
一部の学生で働くことです。 地元の場所な
ので、日本は一般的
に、
この人が
証明書のようなn1 @ jlptライセンス証明書のようなライセンスを持っているようなライセンスを見たい
場合、英語でこれをどのように言うかを好む可能性があります。
大学の学位を取得することは
役に立ちますが、これは
ゆっくりと衰退する傾向だと思います。
日本の企業で
は、単なる紙の資格ではなく、具体的なスキルを検討する企業が増えると思い
ます。 奨学金とそれに伴う潜在的なスキル
があるので
、大学に行っ
て学位を取得するために働いている間に日本に行く間に認定を取得することは悪い考えではないと思いますが、それはそうではないと思います
奨学金の取得方法は大丈夫
です。
東京大学が他の
大学のキャンパスライフや他の大学の
共通文化ショック問題などへのアクセスをどの
ように処理するかについて、日本人の基本レベルは必要
です。ここでたくさんの質問があります。 奨学金
を取得するためのこれらすべての本当に簡単な方法を通過
する各大学に固有の多くの奨学金がある
ので
、申請書に記入しながらそれらの奨学金に
申請するので、あなたが提供し
た申請プロセス中にさまざまな奨学金に申請
することができます
20％、40％、60％、80％、100％の奨学金
を考えてみてください。そうすれば、彼らは留学生にさまざまな奨学金を提供
します。 プロセスと
記録のために、申請プロセスは、米国または
英国の英国の大学のそれとほぼ同じである
ため、あなた
は彼らにあなたの成績を送り、あなたは彼らにあなたが持って
いる
リーダーシップ経験の証拠
を送るでしょう。 持っていて、
なぜあなたはその特定の大学に行きたいのかについてあなたのエッセイを書くでしょう、
そしてあなたはそれ
について具体的にしなければなり
ません
どんな大学のピオでも
、できるだけ具体的にしたい
ので、少しでも役立つ
といいのですが、申請プロセスを通過した場合は
、書面による申請プロセス
に応じて、Skype面接または対面面接があります。
APUが世界中にオフィスを持っていたので、あなたが世界のどこに住んでいるかについて
、そして
あなたがそれを通過した場合、私は
そうだったかもしれないと信じています
学生がそうしなければならない2つの
ことも、申請プロセス
は米国とほぼ同じ
ですが
、政府は
多くのことで非常に遅いため、日本は紙を必要とするため、もう少し紙が必要になる可能性があります アメリカの
ようにオンラインですべて
を行うことはできません。実際に書類に記入するなど、多くのことをしなければなりませ
ん。それはあまり良くありませんが、必要な日本語の基本レベル
は大学
によって異なります。 私がちょうど言及したので
、
私はあなたにIU寺院がアジア太平洋大学で作られているのを見ます、
そして他の
大学で作る必要がある通常の必要性
ソフィアはすべて少なくとも
いくつかのプログラムを提供してい
ます 英語なので、APUは
両方の言語ですべての学部コースを
提供しています。たとえば
、英語で提供しているコースはほんの一握りですが、
OhwahSitaのように 彼らが提供するコースはすべて
、その中で彼ら
が提供する英語のコースが好きな
ので、いわばパイの小さなカットですが、
それでもかなり大きいですそれでも
かなり大きいですKOは一種のようなものだと
思います もう一度、
あなたは完全に英語であると私は信じていると思います
ドン私はまた、
完全に英語ではないにし
ても、確かに多くの英語の
機会があると信じています寺院は
ちょうど日本にあるアメリカの大学な
ので、明らかに彼らは英語のコースを提供しています
ソフィアもハチに似
ていますが、英語でさらに多くのコースを提供しているという意味で、規模が少し大きいと思います。
英語私は
彼らが持っているコースの多くは人類学が好きで
、また心理学やそのようなものが好き
だと私は信じていますあなたはそれらのコースを受講できると信じています
これは大学によって明らかに異なりますが、英語でもそう
です。宿題は、
最初に何をしたいのかを正確
に把握してから、どの大学
があなたの将来の目標に最も適しているかを判断し
ます。
答えは大学ですが、少なくとも学部レベルではほとんどの人が想定し
ているよりもはるかに少ない日本人が必要です。
東京大学は他の大学とどのように関係している
ので、東京大学は
日本で最高の大学であり、
本当に天才です。 日本では、そもそもIQ
が非常に
高いか、
非常に明るい人は天才のようではないかもしれませんが、
基本的に東京大学に入学するために一生ノンストップで勉強している
ので、みんな それ
は東京大学にあるので、
非常に賢いか、非常に賢く
、非常に意欲的であるため
、東京大学は
いくつかを提供していると思います これらのコースはありますが
、
東京大学は、日本で大学院に進学しない限り、直接
留学するよりも、留学するのに適した場所であると私は理解して
います。
東京の
大学は日本で最高の大学ですが、それでも
別のグループの中には
、これらの新しい種類のグループよりもはるかに伝統的なグループのようなもの
です。 新興の
国際大学やグローバル化を
重視している古い大学な
ので、
興味があれば東京大学を
チェックしてみてください。
他の大学と比べてあまりよくわかりません。
この時点まで、
キャンパスライフとほとんどの大学の住宅へのアクセス
について話しましたが、
例としては、
すべての宇宙のすべての留学生が集まる寮があり
ました。  dは少なくとも1年は住むことができ
、その後
は普通のアパートに引っ越して、
1年後には東京のKoに留学していたときに日本の普通の生活に慣れることを余儀なくされました。
留学生用の寮も複数ある寮に
住んでいたのですが、6ヶ月間住んでいました
が、寮は一般
的に自分のような他の留学生でいっぱいで
、私の主な目標
は 留学はできるだけ多くの日本語を学ぶ
ことだったので、koが留学生に
ホームステイオプションを提供し
始めたとき、彼らは
私がそこにいる間に
すぐにそれを申請し
、留学の途中
で寮を出て一緒に暮らすことができます
日本人の家族で、それは私の
日本人の能力にとってはかなり良かったで
す。あなたがはるかに少ないので、寮を出た後、私の日本語を話す能力ははるかに急速に向上しました。
おそらく、
もっと日本語を話さなければなら
ないのかもしれません
が、今夜は友達のよう
に寮で遊ん
でいたので、外出するのではなくビデオゲームをプレイします。
日本で何かを体験するので、
ほとんどの大学には寮
がありますが、可能であれば
、あなたの主な目標の1つが
できるだけ日本語を上手にすることである場合
は、ホームステイで
大丈夫なキャンパスライフで共通の文化にアクセスするのが賢明です。
ショックの問題申し訳ありませんが
、娘が泣いているので
はないかと思いました。彼女が文化だとは思いません。
ショック
はあなたの出身の文化によって異なります
が、日本では日本の文化は
もっと一般的に非常に注意深く、
少なくとも西側と比べると、物事は非常に計画されているので、たくさんの赤いテープ
があります。おそらく、
たくさんの赤いテープの準備ができ
ていて、人々はそれに備えていると思います。
一見シンプルに見えることを成し遂げるのに長い時間
がかかる基本的に
は日本のどの大学でもいいと思います
このビデオのタイミングは完璧
です2020年に日本で勉強する予定
ですこのビデオで奨学金をカバーしますか
はい、奨学金は
主にその大学の文部科学省に固有のものです。私の
理解で
は、ツイッターでマックストンについて少し会ったある種のいい人に
聞いてみよう
と思います。 知識は
、特定の
国に住んでいて、特定の収入レベルを下回っている学生のみが利用できます。
たとえば
、バングラデシュがリストに含まれていることを知って
います。ここにはバングラデシュからの奨学金を
受けている
学生がいますが、バングラデシュからの資格のない自己資金の学生もいます。
奨学金のために他の
奨学金他の奨学金
大学や大学は
独自の内部奨学金や免除を持っているかも
しれません
名前のない私たちの大学では、実際にその
大学を資格のある大学に登録
する必要があります。必要性を
証明できる学生は、家族から疎遠になっている
こと、または家族が
特定の収入ラインを下回っていることを証明する必要があります。 貧困
ラインでは、これは自動的
に、ここで学生ビザを取得
して
いる人は、そもそも
ビザを取得するために自分自身をサポートするための経済的手段があることを証明する必要があるため、資格がないことを意味します。
あなたの質問に答えますそれ
は大学に大きく依存しています私は本当に
この胸のX線を取得する必要
がありますあなたは大学がそうするように求めて
いることを知って
います 日本
に来る前に知らないかも
しれない病気がないことを確認してください。
ホモがジュールであるかどうかにかかわらず、それは私のアプリケーションにも
役立ちます。 あなたの日本語が
一般的に役立つ
ほど、あなたの日本語が一般的に役立つほど、それ
はおそらく私がその特定の問題について
私が与えることができる最善のアドバイスだと思います
が、
それは必ずしも必要ではなく、何ですか
つまり、
100種類のベースポイントがあり、
成績が
非常に良く、日本語がとても上手で、見栄えが良い
場合は、さまざまなスキルすべてに割り当てることができますが、他の誰かがそれらを持っている場合は
、 あなたに割り当てられた同じポイントは本当に良い成績を知っています
が、
リーダーシップの機会もたくさんあります私は
これらの2つの
アプリケーションのどちらかが他よりも実際に目立つとは思わない
ので本当に日本語
はケーキの上のアイシングのような
ものです あなたは一般的にバランスの取れたものになりたいと思っています
、そして
あなたがより良い日本語能力を持っていることを
覚えておいてください、しかし
私が先に述べた様々なプログラムに加えて
あなたは登録することができます ずっと英語で勉強し
、途中で日本語を学び、
後で日本語コースに切り替えます。
それに興味がある
場合は、日本語に堪能で
、2つまたはn1iを持っていても可能です。  n1は
少なくともPUでした。もしあなたが日本語レベル
がそもそもそんなに高いなら、あなた
は英語を知る必要さえありません。あなたは
ただ日本の大学に入学して、最初
から日本語で勉強すること
ができます。 そもそも日本に来る前に
その能力を持っている学生はごく少数ですが、それは
別の可能な
選択肢なので、英語で応募している
ほとんどの留学生にとって、日本語の能力だけが単なるアイシングの
ようなものです。 セカンダリーを投稿
します。後でその質問を
します。
これは、私が標準の
日本語を完全に理解するために、またはこれを完全に理解するために、どのくらいの期間勉強する必要があるかについて、少し複雑です。 かなりの量を勉強すれ
ば、会話が流暢になるまでに日本に住むのに約1年かかり
ます。
そして、熱心に勉強すれば、日本語でコース
を受講できるようになるまでに、おそらくもう1年かかり
ます。日本の
博士号はどうですか。
通常の要件プロセス大丈夫私は
博士号についてかなりの量の質問を受けましたが、
私は多くの学部生をカバーした
ので、私は
Twitterで会ったこの友人に戻り
ます。
大学院生や博士号を取得しようとしている学生の方が多い
ので、彼が私に言ったことを読むつもり
です。それはあなたが
どこから来たの
か、そしてあなたの国が
あなたの フィールドで働くことを計画
している
場合、日本で幹部で働きたい場合は、そこでシステムを通過する必要があります。
ここでシステムを通過するのが最善
です。天体物理学や癌研究のための生化学などのフィールドがあります。
日本が得意
で多くの国が
実践的な実験教育を提供でき
ないearch日本の施設は
最先端であり
、X国のX大学から
非常に優れた研究を行っている学生を訪問させました。  -最先端の
研究と学生たちは
私たちの学生ラボ施設に完全に嫉妬していました
悲しいことに、私たちの学生
は彼らの幸運を最大限に活用する方法を本当に知り
ません、そして私たちは持っていますそして私たちは
あまり最先端の研究を行っていませ
ん 日本の施設は
一般的に非常に進んでおり
、博士号を取得しようとしている多くの人や
大学院生にとって、日本は潜在的な問題の1つ
だと思いますが、アドバイスは
あなたが何をするかという意味で良いと思います。
研究が集中する
ほど、まったく別の場所で非常に熱く使用できる可能性が低くなり
ます。そのため、日本でロボット工学が再び行われているように、もしあなたが死んでしまったら
、 日本のロボット工学の博士号は
おそらく良い考えですが、
ボストンダイナミクスのように行き、
そこでロボットを勉強し
たいのであれば、MITのように行ってみてください。
質問に戻り
ましょう。もう少し失くしてしまいました。もう少し下にスクロールしてみましょう。
キャリアを放棄して
語学学校のビザを取得
してから、直接応募するのではなく、仕事に移行するのは良いことです。 海外でもいいので、これ
も複雑な質問です。
この人
が言いたいのは、日本の大学で
はなく、私立の語学学校のような語学学校に通い
、
あなたの最終目標が日本で働くことで
ある場合
に行く国米国で働くのをやめ
、留学ビザで日本の私立語学学校に行き、そして
日本で仕事を探すことを試みること
そのビザでは可能ですが、それはあなた
が何をしたいかに完全に依存して
いるので
、すでに優れたスキルセットを持っていて、
仕事を失うかやめないことをすでに考え
ていて、やろうとしている人にとっては良いかもしれません 日本では他の何かが
ありますが、米国で良いキャリアパスが進ん
でいて、来年に昇給する準備が
できていること
を知っているなら、おそらくそうは思わないでしょう。
とても良いアイデアなので、それは
あなたの個人的な状況と
あなたがもう一度やりたいことによって大きく異なります多くの人々
は日本でユーチューブになることが今可能であることに気づいていません
そしてあなたが
それをしたいのならそれは実際にはそうではありません
大勢の聴衆がいて税金を払えるなら大学の学位を取得する必要があります。
東京のクリエイティブが今のように、将来的にはさらに多くのスタジオがあり
ます。スポンサーになるだけで取得できる可能性があります。
最初から
あなたはあなたがmすることができます 日本に行って
スポンサーになってもらい、彼らの下で従業員になって
、日本でユーチューバーとして働いてもらいましょう。
東京クリエイティブがまだ
これらのサービスを提供しているかどうかはわかり
ませんが
、将来的にはそのような企業がさらに増えると思います。
再び時代は変わりつつある
ので、大学の
学位とたくさんの学生の借金
が
あなたにとって最善であるかどうかを最初に理解し、将来のあなたの目標
は大丈夫です。
留学することは効果的で、Nレベルのいずれかに座って勉強するのにどれだけ効果的であるか
を学ぶ
ことは何も
ありません。
ここに着いたらすぐに日本語のコースを受講したいのですが
、少なくともAPUには少なくともn2が必要
です。他の大学でも同じだと思いますが、
一般的に、より多くの日本の能力が役立ちます。  sしかし、
それは通常、ケーキの上のアイシングで
あり、語学
学校など、または休暇や専門
学校の最低年齢があり、学校に入学するための勉強が必要です
。18歳だと思います。そうそう、これらの人々
は18歳だと言っています。  're歳も
歳ええ18ごめんなさいokokiko iko 3
ねえ
、留学中に自分をサポートするのはどれほど難しいか大丈夫かもしれません。
プロジェクトなどは大丈夫なので
、これについては前に話しましたが、先ほど触れたすべての大学の中
で最も安い大学の1つに行くとし
ましょう。たとえば
、授業料は
8,000ドル程度になるとしましょう。
11,000ドルや12,000ドルの代わりに
、あなたの成績は最初はかなり良いとし
ましょう。
そうすれば、授業料が30％または30％削減されるので、
下がるのかもしれません。  -
パートタイムの仕事をしている場合、授業料は約
6〜55,000ドルです。合法的に知っていて
も、実際に紙に書いてみたいものよりも通常はお金がかかるので、プライベート英語教育のようなことをし
ます。
あなたがしているどんな仕事もそうすることになっていますが
、英語の教えのようなかなり良いものを手に入れることができれば
、少なくとも1つを手に入れることはそれほど難しくないだろうと思います
リラックスして毎週自分の時間を過ごすために2日間休み
ます。それがあなたの質問に答えてくれることを願っています。また
、あなたがこれについて言及したいのですが、
YouTubeは、YouTube
やTwitter、またはそれが
1つの選択肢かもしれません。 聴衆の大きさや制作量などに応じて、日本で勉強し
ているときに自分をサポートするために使用できる
ので、
もう一度考えてみてください。
なぜあなたの税金や
そのようなものが
合法性に巻き込まれたくないのかを理解し
ていることを確認してください。だからあなたがすべてのことを理解していることを確認してください。
私立大学または公立
大学なので、私立大学は
通常、その一般的な球場で約1万ドルですが、
公立大学は、その範囲の周りで
8万6千7
千5千ドルに近く
、どの大学が
私立/公立と見なされますか？
私が今言ったすべての大学が
IU
になると信じています実際には私はハイヨーについて知りません私は
IUICUソフィアを信じてい
ます私は確かにkoとWassadeがAPUと同様に私立大学であることを知って
いますそして
それは 一般的にはメイコンですが、私が
それらの特定の大学に最も精通している
ことを超えてあまり知りませんが、
私が良くなったオクラホマオクラホマはそれらの1つだったかもしれないと思います
がそれは
グローバルセクターのようなものにもっと重点を置いて
いる公立大学かもしれません。そうすれば、
授業料が低くなり、英語でプログラムを提供する公立大学になるかもしれません。
日本語の
会話スキルを身につける上
で、あなたのビデオの1つで、自分だけではなく他の人
と自然な会話をしているのを見てみたいと
思います。申し訳ありませんが、これ
については少し前に話しましたが
、 できればホームステイのようにやっ
てみてください。でも、できるだけ多くのことをやってみたいと思っています。
これは、
外国人の友達を作っている多くの日本人学生や外国人の
友達について話すのに良いことです。 日本語の
友達を作っているのは、
外国人の友達や日本人の
友達を作って、自分の日本語
能力を向上させ
たいということです。
これらの大学が
あなたのために作成するrtnerプログラムは、実際にはそれほど効果的ではありません。
なぜなら
、あなたがあなた自身の言語で話すその特定の人と過ごす時間の半分は、
彼らがあなたに日本語を教えるのではなく、あなた自身の言語を教えるからです。
50％が英語になるよりも50％くらいになるので、
京尾大学にいたときにやろうとしたのは、
実際にはできるだけ少ない
クラスで、
Sulemanのクラスをスキップすることもありました。 英語を話す
ことに興味のない日本人の友達とたむろするために、
彼らは
私が騙して出会ったブレイクダンスの友達のような日本人
で、騙してブレイクダンスに興味を持っていた
ので、私たちはいつも日本語で交流しまし
た。
あなたの日本人
は、ヒップホップダンスサークルのように参加するほうが、
おそらく伝統的な日本のダンスサークルのように参加するよりも、おそらく伝統的な日本のダンスサークルの
ように参加する
ほうがよいでしょう。 アンゲージパートナーのコーヒータイムサークルなど
は
、通常、同じ考えを持つ他の学生
の存在から何らかの利益を得ようとしている学生の集まりの
ようなものです。
そうそう
、翻訳者としての再開の観点から、そのミューリーに任せてください。
あなたの
母国またはあなたのターゲット国からの証明書の学位を持っている方がいいですうーん、
それは
あなたがやろうとしている翻訳の種類に依存しますあなたがたくさんの日本語から英語に翻訳するつもりなら私は言い
たいです
おそらく通常の標準的な
英米系アメリカ人の証明書のほとんどは
問題ありませんが
、英語から
日本語に変わるので、日本語を母国語としない人にとっては非常に
困難ですが、おそらく追加の
日本語の母国語の証明書が必要になりますが、 私は
皆、これ
はあなたが本当にやりたいことであるか、翻訳であると言われるべきだと思うからといって、これもまた本当に速いと言っ
ています
来年は学士号を取得できますが、英語の翻訳をしたいのであれば、日本で英語を
教えることの論理的な延長のようなものです。
具体的な質問はありませんので
、このビデオから何かをピックアップできることを願っています。
一般的なアドバイスをお伝えしたいのですが、これ
はアメリカの大学にも
当てはまり、習得した知識とスキルの量に
も当てはまります。 大学の意志は、大学自体の質ではなく、
あなたがどれだけの努力を惜しまないかに完全に依存している
ので、
それはグッドウィル
ハンティングであり、主な治療法は
善意であったと思うので、マットデイモンはあなたに言ったと
思います あなたがハーバードに行くことを知っていますが
、この長い雄弁であなたがちょうど私に言ったすべては、あなた
が地元の図書館で本から無料で学んだかもしれない経済学について話すのが好きなので
、スキルの大部分 lsと
彼らが大学から習得できる知識は、それらのスキルを習得するため
にどれだけの努力を払うかに依存するため、知っておくとよいでしょ
う。
その
ため、将来の明確なビジョンを持つことが非常に重要
です。 あなたが大学をただうろついているようなものを知らず
、あなたの道に来る多くの機会を無駄にして
いる
ので、覚えておくと良いことの1つ
は、1秒大丈夫です。
実際に起こったことは、私の
もう一人の娘がこれよりずっと遅く眠りに落ち
たので、これは
すでに起きていて、もう一人は
あなたがしばらく目覚めないことはないので
、
私がまだ試したいことを教えてください これらの質問の多くに答えますが、
明らかにこのようなビデオを完成させることはできないので、今すぐ始める必要があります。
そのため、
このビデオをアップロードしてから
、やや近い将来
、次のビデオではなく、 やってみよう
このような別のビデオを作成する前に、いくつかのコメディービデオを作成しますが
、近い将来、日本への
留学に関する質問に答えるだけで
、私ができなかったさまざまな質問に答える別のビデオを作成する予定です。
まだ答えてください。ファンの皆さん、お詫びする必要があります。今日は
早めに物事を中断しなければならなかった
ことをお詫びします。
明日8月
日水曜日の2:001:45から
2:00pm頃にストリーミング配信する新しいTwitchチャンネルに興味を持ってください それは私が始めようとしているときであり、
それから私は約1時間1時間半ストリーミングする
ので、
twitch.tvスラッシュ道元に興味がある人は誰でも
そこであなたに会いたいと思っています。
次の音声学のレッスンを終えた後の
レッスン、それ以外
はすべて元気だと思います。
次のビデオでまたお会いしましょう。今後ともよろしくお願いいたします。またお話しできること
を楽しみ
にしております。
知る